this video is proudly sponsored by
squarespace
so on this channel i talk all the time
about this exercise and that that
provides all these different functional
benefits all at once but the grand daddy
of them all when it comes to functional
training should probably be the
kettlebell swing kettlebell swing is so
incredibly effective at so many
different things that it has a whole
term named after it called the what's
the hell effect and this is because when
people use the kettlebell swing and they
see their sprint times improve their
jump height improve their deadlift
improve their back strength they say
what the hell the kettlebell swing truly
does transfer to a whole range of
different things and it can have
specific benefits depending on how you
apply it specifically today we're going
to be talking about a variation akin to
the hard style kettlebell swing so in
the hard style kettlebell swing the
focus is on generating massive power in
a manner that should translate to more
powerful strikes martial arts and
greater athleticism can also build your
posterior chain like nothing else
helping you to improve your deadlift
helping you to move better and more
healthily throughout the day helping you
to jump higher it's just an all-round
incredible exercise
so the kettlebell swing is of course a
hip hinge movement and that's where a
lot of its benefits come from because
it's an explosive hip hinge when you
perform a vertical jump you need to
perform kind of explosive hip hinge as
you bring your torso up at the same time
as driving through your legs performing
just a deadlift or something you're
performing the same movement very slowly
whereas the kettlebell swing teaches you
to explode through that range of motion
so it makes sense this will transfer to
a greater jump height and of course to
do this properly you should be driving
through the glutes and the glutes are
often described as your primary
anti-gravity muscles they're the ones
responsible for your ability to jump and
leap and sprint to a certain extent so
if you're not training your glutes
maximally they're not going to be
getting the most out of your athletic
performance at the same time though this
is very similar to a deadlift you're
strengthening the lower back in the same
way but because you're able to do this
for higher rep ranges typically this
allows you to build only strength in the
lower back but strength endurance by
building up strength and joints in this
area we can make sure that we're strong
and stable there all throughout the day
and we can teach the correct hip hinge
movement so that you're not bending that
lower spine and potentially putting it
through unnecessary stress at the same
time the kettlebell swing will help to
strengthen your core and your upper back
your thoracic spine because this is an
anti-flexion movement so when the bell
moves forwards like this the momentum is
trying to pull you forwards your job is
to keep your back straight and upright
in fact if you're doing it right you
should have your back straight and you
shouldn't be bending forwards with it
this allows you to resist forces that
are pulling that way on you and that's
really important because when you carry
anything heavy that's what you're doing
you're holding it in front of you and
you're preventing yourself from flexing
so many of our exercises are flexion
exercises or their anti-extension in
other words we're bending forwards
against resistance or we're trying to
keep our body rigid when something is
trying to pull us backwards so in other
words we're always fighting something
pulling us backwards and we're hunched
over in everyday life anyways when you
sit at a computer you're hunched over
when you look at your phone you're
hunched over in other words we need more
things teaching us to extend our spine
and to give our core strong in that
direction and the kettlebell swing is
the perfect candidate for that other
swings are also really good for your
grip because as the weight is trying to
get away from you you need to hold on to
it as hard as you can and that bar tends
to slip around inside your hand this is
a great way to build up grip strength
without even really trying pavel
satsulin describes kettlebell swings as
the closest thing to a fight as you're
going to get without stepping into the
ring that's a cool sounding statement
that doesn't really mean all that much
but i do get what he's getting at
basically it's a kind of exercise that's
quite unique in that you're battling
against this momentum these forces that
are pulling and tugging and you have to
brace your core at the same time as
driving power through your hips
something quite unlike most exercises
that we are used to using in the gym and
of course kettlebell swing is fantastic
as a form of metabolic conditioning
calorie burning a cardio finisher
however you want to use it it's
brilliant for getting blood pumping
around the body burning through energy
if you want to get a more ripped
physique it's an ideal choice because
the kettlebell swing has a kind of
momentum to it a kind of cyclical
movement this makes it perfect for using
for higher rep counts and you can do it
for 50 repetitions 100 repetitions just
make sure you're using the right weight
of course and your technique isn't
breaking down and for anyone who wants
to burn muscle whilst also burning fat
it's a great choice because it's
resistance cardio meaning that it's a
form of cardio that also incorporates an
element of resistance which is better
for conserving muscle as you're burning
through fat and for anyone who just
wants to burn fat and get a better
physique it's better for burning fats
because muscle has a higher metabolic
cost than fat just being more muscular
burns more fat and having extra
resistance means that you can actually
put more effort into a shorter bout of
exercise this is what makes it fantastic
for high intensity interval training for
tabata anything like that
you've grown since last time i saw you
so to perform the kettlebell swing what
you're going to do is you're going to
grab your bell end
grab your kettlebell by the handle and
hold it
in the middle like this with both hands
legs shoulder width apart roughly and
what you're going to do is you're going
to thrust forwards with your hips
which is going to be what drives the
kettlebell up the key thing to recognize
here is that this is not a squat you're
not squatting down with your legs in
fact your legs are going to be slightly
bent let them bend naturally but don't
put any work into squatting down as you
swing now there is such thing as a
squatting kettlebell swing and this
actually creates more ground reaction
force but that's not your classic bread
and butter kettlebell swing rather like
i say you're hinging at the hips that
means you're letting your butt move
backwards
and then thrusting forwards
in order to drive it upwards into the
air
in order to drive the hips forwards
you're contracting the glutes and you
should feel this in your glutes if
you're doing it correctly you're going
to let the hip hinge once your arms
touch your legs like so so you're not
really moving the waist
until about that point
you might be nervous that you're going
to hit yourself in the crotch but i've
literally never seen anyone do that
i mean of course you might be the first
but it's not highly likely comes forward
you want to keep your core nice and
rigid again this is an anti-flexion
movement you're trying to prevent your
spine from bending forwards you want to
keep the weight quite close to your body
so when it comes upwards have those
shoulder blades retracted
and you can bend the arms
so you don't want it swinging all the
way over there you want to keep it nice
and tight
to the body
you want to make sure we're hinging at
the hips properly and i've talked in the
past about the butt touch i'll
demonstrate it once more here this is
where you stand in front of a wall or
tree any kind of flat surface and then
move your butt backwards to touch the
wall behind you and instead of bending
forwards we're focusing on moving the
butt backwards and if you're still not
sure if you're engaging your glutes
properly i recommend trying something
like the glute bridge which is a great
way to really feel whether or not you're
activating your butt i want to
demonstrate to you how to do the glute
bridge but this whole area is covered in
sheep poo which i didn't really expect
so i'm going to go somewhere else i
think
with that in mind you're about to see
something you don't see very often on
this channel i'm going to put my top
back on i think
i know
so to perform this movement just going
to get on the floor then you're going to
get to a bridge a half bridge with your
shoulders on the floor and then you're
just going to thrust your crotch up into
the sky like so
and if you feel it in your quads or your
back then you're not doing it correctly
and what you want to do now then is
contract the glutes consciously as you
go through this movement push through
your heels and focus on pushing your
crotch up to the sky what you can also
do is get someone to put their hands on
either side of your knees and you try
and push them outwards as you go through
the movement this is another really good
way to engage the glutes if you practice
this commonly you'll find you actually
start to use your glutes more in regular
movements and then when you perform the
kettlebell swing you'll feel it in the
glutes they'll feel like rocks in your
trousers and you just unlocked the
kettlebell swing now keep going on about
how there are different types of
kettlebell swing and how they provide
different benefit so we've been talking
about something like the hard style
kettlebell swing so in the sports style
essentially what you're doing is you're
allowing momentum to carry you as much
as possible and you're trying to make it
as efficient as possible so you're
expending as little energy as possible
this might mean that there's slightly
more of a squat involved or that you
straighten your legs at the bottom of
the movement the whole thing looks more
like a pendulum on the other hand the
hard style kettlebell swing is a form of
kettlebell training that involves
relaxing the body yes but then during
the hip thrust you're going to really
contract as hard as you can and this is
the nuance the important feature of hard
style kettlebell training because what
you're doing is you're trying to quickly
switch between complete relaxation and
then sudden hard contraction and this is
what we do in martial arts for example
in order to deliver the most power
possible we want to be fully relaxed and
then contract powerfully on the moment
of impact and that's what we're trying
to emulate with the hard style
kettlebell swing you also really
emphasize the breathing the outward
breath on the contraction in the hard
style
all the difference is internal it's the
way you're focusing on the movement
where you're generating the power and
this is what i find so really
interesting about it the two versions of
the same exercise that look almost
identical but by changing what you're
focusing on you can completely alter the
benefits that you're getting of course
the sport style being better for longer
rep ranges and therefore cardio and the
hard style being better for martial
artists as well as athletes who also
exhibit a kind of double pulse effect
when producing power relaxation and
contraction relaxation in the right
parts of the body contraction in the
right muscles what's possibly even
cooler is the overspeed kettlebell swing
which also has one of the neatest names
in the world basically what you're doing
here is you're actively swinging the
kettlebell back down so that you have to
catch it and propel it back up forwards
this downwards force this additional
downward force emphasizes the stretch
shortening cycle the myotastic response
and could help to build even more
explosive athleticism the jumping
kettlebell squat where you hold the
kettlebell in a goblet position is
actually the perfect complement to the
kettlebell swing because here you are
creating a triple extension as you
launch up into the air and then drive
through the ankles as well as you
plantarflex to push yourself off and
that lasts a little bit at the same time
because the weight's in front of you you
have to extend upwards hinge the hip
against that added resistance keeping
yourself nice and rigid and creating
that explosive force then there are
variations like kettlebell juggling
which creates more momentum and you've
got to slow that momentum this also
creates more of a engaging challenge for
the nervous system and of course just
one armed kettlebell swings which
require further bracing in the course
draw now keep your body nice and
straight instead of twisting around
awkwardly then of course you can also
use the kettlebell swing to transition
into a range of other movements for all
kinds of cool flows switching between
these creates a hybrid exercise which
means you're not only challenging
yourself in all of these different
positions but also in the ability to
transition between the positions
thanks a ton for watching guys i hope
you found this video useful and
interesting if you did please consider
leaving a like that helps me out
immensely leave a comment down below let
me know if you use the kettlebell swing
and what's your favorite type if you do
are there any that i've missed if you
like the style of training that looks at
not only aesthetics and building muscle
but also your actual performance across
the board that means running speed
jumping height mobility focus strength
explosiveness cardio all that good stuff
and you might enjoy my ebook and
training program super functional
training 2.0 there's a link to that in
description down below also comes with
over two hours of video tutorial
subscribe if you'd like to see more like
this and either way thank you so much
for watching and i'll see you next time
bye for now oh hey you're still here
tonight i'd like to take a moment to
talk about today's sponsor squarespace
so squarespace is a platform for
creating websites whether you want to
start your own business whether you
already have a business or you just want
to express yourself online squarespace
makes it extremely easy to create a
website with no coding necessary and
minimal technical expertise required
squarespace comes packed with features
so there's no limit to what you can
create
super easy to create and publish posts
you can schedule posts there's member
management features you can create
members only content which is a great
way to monetize your website you can
send emails directly from the platform
there's analytics so you can track
what's working and what's not and there
are powerful e-commerce features so you
can sell products from your website and
then you can expand on these features
with additional plugins that might mean
adding things like sales tax
reconciliation or global shipping for
the e-commerce features basically if
it's something that you might need to
run a website then squarespace has you
covered and i don't know if it matters
to you guys but squarespace is also
really content creator friendly they let
me post the integrations at the end of
the videos they've supported the channel
loyally for many many months now and
they make it possible for people like me
to create more of the content that i
love so yeah i love supporting
squarespace i think they're a fantastic
company and i think they have a
brilliant tool for anyone interested in
creating art or running a business if
you're interested in trying out
squarespace then go to squarespace.com
to learn more and for a free trial and
when you're ready to pull the trigger
head to the link in the description down
below that's squarespace.com forward
slash bioneer for 10 off your first
website or domain thanks once again to
squarespace for sponsoring this video
and thank you to you guys so much for
sticking around